And of course HAF features in the TV show,
breaking bad,
which I'm glad to say I've never seen or are you glad to say that it's really
good? Well, perhaps perhaps one day I might watch it. When I'm old.
For a long time,
people have wanted to hear what you think of breaking bed before you watched
this episode. What did you know about breaking bed and what were you?
Well, I knew it was about, um,
the chemistry teacher and I knew that he was making,
um, some sort of drug, but I didn't know which one.
And I really didn't know much more about that,
except that I think I heard that there were lots of episodes and
that at some stage HF hydrogen fluoride plays the part,
but that was about it.
Show about chemistry, not attracted you into it.
Well,
I don't actually watch much TV I'm and I watch quite a,
I will until the pandemic. Um,
I went to the cinema quite regularly and obviously breaking by this,
not in the cinema, I suppose
it was not on terrestrial television.
We don't have streaming services on that TV. So I just never watched.
And professor as a chemist, when you make people like, you know, out and about,
is it a common joke for you to have to put up with the cliche of, Oh,
do you know how to make drugs?
No. I mean, it's, I'm not sure anybody's ever asked me.
Well, I mean, you, you have asked me,
but I can't remember anybody else ever asking me.
I've never asked you to make drugs. No, no, no, but I mean,
you've just tells me the question, but no, I've, I've no idea.
I can't remember anybody asking me that. So.
So, so far I've only convinced you to watch the first episode,
the pilot and the pilot starts with this iconic shot of a pair of
trousers floating through the air.
And I get the impression that's one of the shots that made the biggest
impression on you.
Yeah, I really liked it.
I started wondering whether you could fly chances as a parent,
as a kite,
but I was slightly disappointed because given that
later on, you see where the trousers came from.
I think it's physically impossible that it could have been run over by the van
that the teacher was driving. But, um,
the floated chancellor's was really good.
They look a bit like a pair of trousers you'd wear. No, no, I don't think so.
No. Well, possibly, but I'm not very,
very fussy about clothes. Good clothes.
Okay. Go home smelling like a metal lab after the introductory sequence,
we have like the title screen for the show, which involves breaking bad,
been written with bromine and barium and the periodic table and all these sort
of, uh, chemistry formula. I thought that would really excite you.
Yeah. I thought that was quite clever.
I thought it was a bit more subtle than these things where they're
drawn like element symbols with the atomic weights and so on in as
well. And I quite like that.
And I started thinking how my name could be spelled with
Algon and Martin.
And I couldn't decide whether polonium or lithium would
look better. In public.
Episode.
We see Walter the star of the show in a chemistry setting as a teacher
with his students for no, you know,
five minutes or so trying to conduct a chemistry class. Well that's,
that's all of life, right? It's just, it's the constant, it's the cycle. It's.
The lesson was quite good that there were one or two things.
One thing I really liked was his flame tests,
which I thought were really good where he sprayed something that gave a red and
a green color.
I think it was probably copper and barium that could have been strong, Tim,
but strontium might have been a bit exotic for the props
departments of the show. There were other things that were quite strange,
particularly in the view of him,
Walter being rather safety conscious later on that he was not wearing safety
glasses.
I also was quite interested in him asking what chemistry was
not. So anybody's been asked me that my son,
when he was at taste school was asked what is in organic chemistry.
And he said, it didn't a rather loud whisper to his friends.
That's what my dad does.
Chemistry is the study of matter,
but I prefer to see it as the study of change.
Walter's answered.
The T was the study of change would have been better if he
mixed it up with the other definition, which was study of matter.
And if you'd say it was the way that matter changes,
I think that might have been quite good.
I was also not totally convinced by him lighting a Bunsen
burner and saying that that was electrons, lighting the burner.
But overall,
I thought the reaction of the class was a
bit disappointing from what was quite exciting
chemistry teacher.
I think chemistry being the study of change was a really nice answer. I mean,
obviously it also foreshadows what's going to happen in this television show,
but, um, but I that's a, quite a, quite a poetic, there was.
One thing that struck me about him is that he looks quite like a
well-known richest scientist, Robert Winston,
who's quite a famous popularized sort of science or used to be.
I know very few chemists that have mustaches actually later on or
quite shortly after that scene.
You'll see that he's got a second job in the carwash.
Um, I don't know how you described it,
a manual car wash and that
underlines quite an important point.
I think that chemistry teachers or science teachers often don't
have the social status that they really want to have because it's
such an important job.
I'm not sure that that's the point that they were trying to make in this
particular film. But I think it's quite an important thing to see.
I think the point they're trying to make is that chemistry teachers don't earn a
lot of money, which is the whole reason that he breaks bad.
Yeah. I mean, that might be true, but, um,
I D I've never idea what chemistry teachers are. Actually.
We also see a scene shortly after when he,
when he's looting the school lab and he's taking all sorts of things from the,
uh, from the shelves. I thought you must have frowned upon that.
You're a bit of a goody two-shoes.
Was I shocked by his dishonesty? Um,
well that was part of the story, wasn't it?
But what surprised me a bit more was the
size of flasks that they had in the, um,
schools store, particularly the, um, they,
they all were in a much larger scale than I would have expected in the school
chemistry lamp.
Shortly after the theft. We see him talking with Jesse about, uh, you know,
preparing to make the crystal meth.
And he had monitored him for cooking with a volumetric flask rather than a
cooking flask.
And like I thought you'd like that getting a little bit of a little bit of
teaching in there about how to use the equipment.
No, this is a volumetric flask. You wouldn't cook in one of these. Uh, yeah,
I do. Uh, no you don't.
Yes. I think I'm in that. That was quite nice. And, um, the,
I must say earlier in my career when I didn't know things so
well, I try to cook in a volumetric flask,
but I think that the two, th th the,
there there's something that I felt didn't ring very true with his first meeting
with Jesse,
when Jesse escapes from the police raid,
Jesse has already left the school and Walter recognizes him.
Honestly, I never expected you to amount to much, but I then fettuccine.
I didn't picture that.
And certainly as a university teacher,
I rarely recognize students when they come back because they've changed,
they've grown up.
So I wasn't sure that Walter would have immediately recognized two
students. On the other hand, it's clear that he,
although Jesse was a bad student that will still manage to teach him
something.
Metric flask is for general mixing and titration.
You wouldn't apply heat to a volumetric class.
That's what a boiling flask is for.
Did you learn nothing from my chemistry class? No. You flunked me.
There's this interaction between them, where, um,
they're talking about the cooking, the preparation of crystal meth,
and Jesse says it's an art.
Cooking is art. I saw your set up at ridiculous.
You and I will not make garbage.
We will produce a chemically pure and stable product that performs this
advertised. No, adulterants no baby formula, no chili pie, chili peas,
my signature.
Well, just not having any of that. He says, this is not art.
This is just pure and simple chemistry. Where would you come down on?
Is there art to chemistry? Well,
I think there is art in doing preparative chemistry. Well,
I've never been a very good prep chemist,
and that's why in the later stages of my career,
I have built the machines to make chemicals because I'm not very good at
manipulating them.
So I think there is quite a lot of art and particularly organic chemists.
Very much believe that what they do is an art as well as
being a science, a real theme that runs through this scene as well is like,
even though he's doing something bad,
Walter is taking a real pride in the chemistry, isn't he, he says,
we're going to produce things that are pure and stable.
There's a real kind of chemists pride in him, despite what he's doing. Yeah,
very much. So. Um,
you mentioned cooking the drugs and I,
there was that Jessica calls themselves captain cook,
which for you as an Australian,
and for me would have raised the idea of captain cook, the Explorer,
which perhaps won't have resonated so much with the American
audience. And also, I remember that captain cook was murdered.
So I wonder where the,
this is something that is going to happen in the later episode. Oh, look,
you're already thinking. I like it. Also,
we see Walter talking to Jesse about wanting to put safety,
like an eyewash station in place, and he's very sort of safety conscious.
I know you used to be the health and safety officer for your chemistry
department with were glowing with pride at that point. Yeah.
I was very pleased with that though. As I pointed out,
Walter wasn't wearing safety glasses when demonstrating to the students
and the students setting not far from the bench,
weren't wearing safety glasses either
though I was a bit surprised by the safety
equipment that Walter used when he was started making his,
um, crystal meth,
where he was wearing a leather apron and his
underpants and nothing else.
And I would have thought he would have been wearing, um,
a lab coat though, sin from the point of view of the drama,
it would not have looked quite as good wearing a lab coat.
Once when I was working in a lab in my previous
university, which was very hot, 37 degrees centigrade,
nearly bought the heat. I wore a lab coat,
but stripped to the waist. So I was just,
I was just wearing trousers and a lab coat because it was so
hot, but I still wore a lab coat. You've never done chemistry.
And just your underwear. No.
At this point we have this montage. When he, when he makes the crystal meth,
you know, it's quite a stylistic and fast editing and things like that,
but we do see lots of equipment and powders and things being poured.
And it's our first real kind of look at lots and lots of chemistry happening.
What did you think of?
Well, I thought it was quite nice as a montage.
It didn't make any chemical sense at all. First of all,
I should say I had to look up what methamphetamine
was because I didn't know it's formula,
but I don't see why they were using red phosphorus.
And also what looked as if it might have been cobalt,
chloride or cobalt sulfate.
The other thing is I was quite surprised by the volume of fumes
that were coming out to the top of the motor home that they were using as the
lab. So I'm not sure what it was that was coming out,
but I suppose I'm a slightly less worried about
slightly natural causes of the chemistry than the impression of actually doing
it.
And of course he uses chemistry to get out of a pickle with the bad guys in
this scene where he throws down some red phosphorus and there's an explosion.
And then there are fumes that overwhelm the bad guys,
give you any idea what's going on. There is that.
No, I don't think that is,
they said they were making phosphene pH three,
like ammonia, which is NH three,
which burns quite easily. And if they'd had flames,
it would have burnt the false phosphene. And I suspect,
and I haven't calculated this.
If you looked at the volume of the inside of the motor
home and the volume of gas that he might have produced,
they wouldn't have been enough to, um, produce, well, first of all,
the reaction he had probably wouldn't have produced the gas, but ignoring that,
I don't know that it would have produced enough gas to produce the toxic effect
that they said was formed.
And the other thing is I'm not absolutely certain that
the reaction would have happened fast enough for the bad guys
not to shoot him. Anyway,
they were gas masks at the end when the SKUs has been removed.
And I very rarely offense was seen labs with gas masks.
Occasionally you have breathing operators in case something goes
wrong, but whether they would have had gas masks that were good enough,
I don't know. But again,
I think you will have to allow a little bit too dramatic license.
There are going to be some
things that you'll come to learn about me in the next few days.
So you finally have watched an episode of breaking bad after all these years.
I cannot tell you how many viewers have asked to know what you think of breaking
bed. You've now seen one episode. What did you think of it?
Just as an overall thing? Not just the chemistry, but just as a, you know,
a piece of story.
So my overall verdict is that it's quite good.
[Inaudible].
Let me just explain for American viewers quite good in English means not bad.
Doesn't mean it's outstanding.
[Inaudible].
I think, I mean,
I was quite pleased to have seen it because I suppose I had some curiosity,
but it was about not.
That much curiosity you've waited this long.
Yeah. Well, I mean, sometimes one has to restrain oneself.
I think I'm in,
it is positive that it's brought chemistry to a wider audience.
I think, well, I don't know how the rest of the story is going to develop.
There are things which struck me like the guns,
that every way of which they're clearly much more common in America than in the
UK.
I'm not sure they knew anybody who's ever handled a pistol.
And it's a long time since I've handled any firearms. But, um,
I think overall it was quite fun. Are you inclined to watch anymore? Um,
how many episodes? All that?
There's quite a few. I think,
I think what a good idea might be just to zero in a bit more on the chemistry.
Now, perhaps some of the viewers would like to suggest scenes and sections or
episodes or parts of the series. They would particularly like you to watch.
And I might be able to put together a bit of a collection for you,
and we could just deal with those rather than the whole series.
I think that's a great idea. Um,
I think I'm always interested how
chemistry is, um,
portrayed in films plays. And so on my brother roots,
my brother is a playwright in case you don't know if you write plays
and films, and there's a film director,
he wrote a play for the national theater about chemistry.
And I had to provide the dialogue about
chemistry for that play.
And on the opening night in the national theater in London,
when one of the actors said hex or fluoro ISO propanol,
I was the only person in the audience who laughed.
Why is that funny?
Well,
I thought it sounded really funny people saying that in the middle of the
national theater, but on the other hand,
I think that anything that brings chemistry to the public
in a way that is not about learning at school,
when people are bored, it's very positive.
I should say about the scene where they
were making the crystal meth.
The first time they got some enormous crystals,
which look really nice.
Glass grade, you got crystals in here, two inches, three inches long.
But that is rather unrealistic because if you want to get big crystals,
you have to grow them very slowly.
I don't think that they were there for days when they were doing the
chemistry or at least in the story.
So that was a bit unrealistic. But on the other hand,
to get the idea that the chemistry teacher could make much better
compounds than his pupil was probably pretty realistic.
The other point which I did notice is that one of the bad guys
was smoking in the lab.
Put the cigarette out,
please.
And Walter stops him because it's dangerous with organic solvents and the
lighted cigarette.
And this reminded me of a friend of mine who was safety
officer for a tobacco company, the labs of the tobacco company.
And he banned smoking.
And he was brought in front of the directors who said,
how's this going to look for our company if we're banning smoking in our lab.
And he replied, well,
how's it going to look for the company if somebody smokes and blows up the whole
lab. So he was allowed to ban it. There is also a story of,
um, the chemist when I was an undergraduate.
One of the professors who was teaching lab classes
was said to her,
been smoking and put a bit of the Ash into the
solution that one of my fellow students was trying to get
crystals from.
And the tiny particles of Ash acted as a nucleus
to start the crystals growing.
And so this solution that wouldn't crystallize suddenly crystallized
beautifully when the cigarette Ash fell in,
I wouldn't for a moment recommend that any of you try smoking in the lab
or anywhere else or anywhere else. Yes.
Most chemists are fascinated by what they've always been told that
HF hydrofluoric acid eats human flesh.